okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness sees wander chasing down
america chavez in order to steal her
powers so that she can be reunited with
her kids though some people are calling
wanda one-dimensional i think she's the
perfect villain for this film which
feels like the first horror movie we've
had in the mcu i know her turn is very
divisive but throughout this video i
want to argue why i absolutely love her
the horror movies that raymie pulled
from to make her seems even more intense
and why she's one of my favorite comic
book movie villains ever if you agree
then please hit the thumbs up button if
you don't then drop a comment below but
whatever you do make sure you subscribe
for videos like this almost every day
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into why we think wonder
is the perfect villain no wonder she's
been through a lot in her life not only
did she get her home blown up along with
her parents she also ended up getting
experimented on by hydra when she was
very young this led into the events of
age of ultron where her brother was
killed in front of her which was then
followed by civil war where the whole
world turned on her and blamed her for
killing lots of kids to add to that when
infinity war rolled around she had to
murder the man she loved to save the
universe but this ended up proving to be
pointless when thanos brought him back
and killed him in front of her then
there was one division where she ended
up creating a perfect life for herself
only to have it all taken away
wanda has been through a lot and since
she was first introduced all the way
back in 2015 she's arguably had the most
tragic arc out of any marvel character
now though there's a lot of criticism
that she ended up doing at daenerys and
going crazy all of a sudden you have to
remember that she was out in the
wilderness with the darkhold for months
most of the time whenever the devil is
described in stories he doesn't come
trying to kill you his tactics are way
more subtle this embodiment of evil is
often just someone who tempts us with
giving up our morals in order to get
what our heart desires that is very much
what the dark old represents and whilst
it corrupts wonder it also offers there
a better life
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair he then gets its
claws and wonder which is why we find
her buried under rubble inside her mind
whilst the scarlet witch is showing up
at breakneck speeds in the film we
discover that every universe other than
the 616 has a version of her where she's
happy with her kids and every night
wonder goes to sleep dreaming of this
better life upon waking up she's faced
with a cold hard truth and even without
the dark hold you can see how this would
break someone mentally no wonder much
like age of ultron was first introduced
as a villain in the comics but over the
years we've watched her transform into a
hero before her power ended up proving
too much in stories like avengers
disassembled and house of m we've seen
how she's been someone who can do
exactly what she wants and therein lies
a downfall like silas stone says in zack
snyder's justice league the question no
the challenge
won't be doing it
it will be not doing
not seeing
wanda is one of if not the most powerful
person in the universe and therefore she
should be able to have what she wants
now her being the villain here makes the
perfect opposite to strange wander isn't
willing to sacrifice what she wants for
the greater good and she will happily
kill that on mother's day just cause
there'll be someone to look after the
kids jerk supposing this strange could
have had a happy life but instead he
sacrificed the time stone got dusted and
came back five years later having found
that the love of his life had moved on
to make things worse her husband is a
massive doctor strange fan and stephen
ends up having to stand at the wedding
pretending to be happy watching her walk
down the aisle wanda also tempts him
with another universe in which he can be
with christine but he turns this down as
the cost of killing america would be too
great for him it puts them at complete
opposite ends of the spectrum and shows
two powerful magic entities that could
both have what they want but they decide
for themselves to take different paths
just before they meet her comitage
wander says that it won't be her that
comes for america it'll be the scholar
witch so her showing up at comitage to
tempt steven when she never did this at
the forest is showing the extent of her
possession she's using the same tactics
that the darkhold used on her in order
to try and tempt steven with a better
life where he will finally obtain the
happiness that he lies about having now
wonder's design in the movie is based
heavily on a lot of horror villains the
samara from the ring whose infamous tv
crawl she imitates when exiting the
mirror dimension the wicked witch of the
west's horned forest trees that we
somewhat see at her home when the
illusion is broken elements of carry
with the oil all over her face
terminator when she limps along after
the heroes with her eyes glowing red
snow white which we even see playing on
a tv in other wonders home the exorcist
when she appears from the corner and
snaps x's neck and there's a lot of
references to past works it plans this
idea on her head that she's a classic
horror monster
who's completely unstoppable when we did
our analysis of the batman we talked
about how matt reeves lean into villains
like michael myers and jason voorhees in
order to give the idea to audiences that
batman was somewhat of a supernatural
being his slow walking was used to
intimidate those that he faced and
wonder very much pulls from these same
archetypes making her a one-dimensional
character also makes her a force of
nature and whenever strange and co
throughout her she has the ability to
get around it and bounce back from it
now i know there's a lot of criticism
about how the illuminati are handled in
this movie but personally i think that
what they do is brilliant to make us
realize just how powerful that wonder is
for years fans have cried out for not
only john krasinski to be fan cast as mr
fantastic but we've also been desperate
to see professor rex in the mcu these
are given to us in the film and just
when we think they're gonna save the day
they're ripped apart by wonder which
also rips our heart out in the audience
look look at me you can see the moment
my heart breaks into watching professor
rex get his neck broken now i think
everyone is going to have a kind of
knee-jerk reaction to it at first but
with the x-men and fantastic four both
getting movies in the future i think
it's safe to say that they'll be back
you will no doubt get them again and
those who hate this might even come to
appreciate how much of a nephew that it
is to fans a ralph boner showed us
fergie likes to troll and watching
warner drop the coldest lines i've ever
heard in a comic book movie just
elevates the scene so much she drops the
what mouth line in bit about sue storm
being that a race reads kids back to
back and it shows how she will no longer
let anyone stand in her way
i'm the smartest man alive
reed richards of the fantastic four
the world's smartest man
poses no more threat to me
than does its smartest termite
now though it's not really labeled as
search this film is very much a versus
movie we've had a number of them over
the years like godzilla vs kong batman v
superman alien vs predator and so on and
so on they're very much a staple of big
franchises and now i like them i have to
admit that at this point they all follow
the same sort of formula when godzilla
vs kong was getting filmed i think we
all knew that it would end with the pair
teaming up together in order to stop a
bigger threat that was actually behind
the scenes controlling it all most of
the movies in the genre and with the two
opposing teams putting their differences
to the side in order to fight a bigger
bad guy and this was even somewhat the
structure that marvel used for captain
america civil war many people even
expected a secret villain in this and
when those catholic monsters showed up
in the trailers it seemed like that was
what we were gonna get what multiverse
of madness does though is that it keeps
the scholar which is the main villain
and because of this it doesn't cheapen
her in the end the dark knight rises
show that you can often strip one of the
main talking points of your film if you
do a bait and switch at the end and i
think it's smart of marvel to just be
like nope wonder is the bad guy the film
ends with her coming face to face with
her children and a version of herself
which she ends up attacking this scares
her kid so much she realizes the monster
that she's become and lies through her
teeth saying that she didn't hurt anyone
she's then faced with a version of
herself who is the mother that she
should be rather than the person she's
become she tells her that they'll be
loved which finally breaks wonder and
makes her realize her wrongdoings even
in this moment scarlet witch is so
powerful that she can only be defeated
by herself and this strategy to take her
into the life she could have makes us
see where she's gone wrong at her core
wonder is still a hero even though we
just watched her brutally murder people
for two hours and over the last seven
years we've followed the growth of the
character as she's went from villain to
hero and back to being a villain she's
arguably been on the most complex arc
out of any mcu character and pushing her
over the deep end like this was not only
surprising but damn right divisive and
for a good reason we often don't want to
see the faults in the heroes that we
respect but watching her corrupted by
her selfish attitude very much acts as
an example to us of what not to do this
is also mirrored and strange who could
potentially be with a version of
christine at the end of the film but he
forgoes this because of the incursion
that it would cause strange is such a
hero in this moment because wanda has
been such a big villain throughout the
movie and then being at opposite sides
of the spectrum is the perfect way to
drive the narrative wonder very much
feels like she's a monster from an 80s
kids movie back before everything got
heavily sanitized and the horror she
brings in the film is used expertly to
tear off finer only the characters in
the movie but also us as an audience
it's masterful storytelling that allows
her to become the perfect villain that
this film needs and in the hands of
anyone else i think that wonder may have
under-delivered instead elizabeth olsen
completely knocks it out the park and
delivers what's probably her most
memorable performance in the mcu scarlet
witch was incredible and hopefully have
helped to make you appreciate the movie
a little bit more if you came out of it
not liking the choices they made
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below so make sure you
drop them and just to let you know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of spider-man
now a home on the 15th of may all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want someone
else to watch them make sure you check
out our breakdown of the unanswered
questions in the movie which goes over a
lot of the things that people are very
confused about hopefully see you over
there but if not enjoy your weekend and
i'll see you next week take care peace